-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You are here.
You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
This is exciting.
Today is World Teachers Day.
So thank you to all
the teachers out there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Actually, I like World
Substitute Teachers Day
because you just sit in a room
and watch a movie all day.
[ Laughter ]
Yep. Every student who gave
their teacher an apple today
got a B-plus
while everyone who gave them
an Apple iPhone 15 got an A.
So just saying.
Just think about it.
Guys, listen to this.
Taylor Swift's Eras Tour movie
comes out next week
and it's already broken
presale records.
Yeah. That's good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So next week,
if you walk past the theater,
you won't know if the screams
are coming from "Saw,"
"Exorcist," or Taylor Swift.
[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
Of course people are going to
dress up and sing along.
So I guess it's fun
when Swifties do it,
but when I do it,
I'm "ruining 'Oppenheimer.'"
[ Laughter ]
Some TV news --
earlier tonight,
there was a new episode
of "The Golden Bachelor."
Yeah. All those senior
citizens in one house.
The medicine cabinet is
the size of a walk-in closet.
[ Laughter ]
Tonight's episode
was kind of slow.
It was just a full hour
of reminding the Bachelor
of what happened last week.
They're like,
"Then you talked to..."
[ Laughter ]
Switching -- "I did what?"
"Yeah, you..."
Switching gears -- some news
from Washington.
After biting multiple staffers
and Secret Service agents,
President Biden's dog Commander
has been removed
from the White House.
[ Audience aws ]
It's not easy to remove
the White House dog.
First the House
has to impeach.
Then the Senate
has to vote to convict.
On the bright side, Commander
got to split an Uber
to the airport
with Kevin McCarthy.
So it's kind of interesting.
Not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They actually got Commander
to leave the White House
the same way they got
Eric Trump to leave.
They just threw
a tennis ball.
[ Laughter ]
[ Barking ]
[ as Trump ] I remember when
Eric barked for the first time.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Some more news
from the White House.
The Biden administration
just announced plans to add
to Trump's border wall in Texas.
And just to mess with Trump,
Mexico is like,
"We'll pay for it."
[ Laughter ]
"Why not?"
-"Here you go."
-"We got this one."
[ Applause ]
They should.
Well, guys, the number-one movie
in the country right now
is "Paw Patrol."
Have you guys seen this?
-Whoo!
-I haven't seen it yet,
but it looks pretty good to me.
If you want a quick refresher,
here's the trailer right here.
-The Paw Patrol is back,
and this time they're taking
on their scariest villain yet.
-President Biden's dog
has bitten somebody else.
It's the Paw Patrol versus
Commander Biden,
now in theaters.
-What's the dog's name?
-Commander.
We just said that.
-Yeah, it is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Looks good. Looks good.
Hey, get this, guys, I read
that Prada is helping design
the spacesuits for NASA's
upcoming mission to the moon.
Can we see the suit?
Wow, looks pretty cool.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
Going with the body on top.
-It looks good.
I think it looks pretty good,
man.
You guys see this?
Manhattan's first public beach
just opened downtown. Yeah.
Nothing says beach season like
downtown Manhattan in October.
[ Laughter ]
Today, someone built
a sandcastle
and then rented it out
for 5,000 a month.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I saw that for Halloween.
Dunkin Donuts has unveiled
a six-foot-tall inflatable
doughnut decoration.
Take a look at this thing.
-Oh!
-Here's something
I learned today.
Once someone tells you
it looks like
Trump's colonoscopy,
you can't unsee it.
Don't show it again.
-Don't look at it.
-You can't unsee it.
[ Applause ]
I don't want to look at it.
You'll have to rewind.
I'm not --
And finally, according
to the latest polls...
[ Laughter ]
You can't unsee it.
-Can't unsee it.
-I didn't do it.
I'm not going to do it.
According to the latest polls,
Higgins,
you'll find this interesting.
-Oh, good.
-Former president Trump still
leading the Republican primary
with 55% of the vote,
followed by Ron DeSantis with 13
and Nikki Haley with 8.
But there's actually a lot
of interesting new data
about the election.
-Really?
-Yeah, check this out.
First up, when asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's how they weighed it.
Here's another one they asked.
They said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'll try it.
Up next, when asked...
[ Laughter ]
-Gah.
-Looks like he's getting felt up
by the TSA or something.
He's like...
[ Laughter ]
Looks like he's waiting
for a ski lift.
Next up, when asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Here's another one.
When asked...
[ Laughter ]
I see it now.
-You can't unsee it.
-I'm hearing Yanni.
I don't know.
When asked...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Check this one out.
Up next, when asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
-Also when asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, when asked...
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a great show tonight!